dude this is a first for number five on
the ribs as well the pain of the rib
steak that's I'm gonna say this is a
complete commitment to two Navia steaks
and fluid mechanics why did you do that
well what are the navier-stokes
equations the first one grad dot u
equals naught and the second one Rho dou
u by DT equals minus grad P plus mu grad
square u Rho like those mathematical
equations perhaps they look quite scary
but they're actually universal laws of
physics so this is why these guys model
every single fluid we have on earth and
I mean every fluid put a fluid in your
head these guys tell you how it moves
how it behaves what's going on with that
fluid and so a fluid I tend to think of
it as something which changes shape to
match the container that it is in of
course a liquid but also a gas even some
solids so like ice do you think about a
glacier flowing down a mountain you
watch those time-lapse videos kinda
looks like a river so ice in that sense
behaves like a fluid it is changing its
shape to fit the valley the glacial
Valley which is flowing it so the first
one this is literally just saying that
mass is conserved so this is just saying
I have some blob of fluid it moves
around you know with some velocity and
maybe changes shape I'm not adding
anything I'm not removing anything I
would want the same mass of fluid to
still be there mass is conserved it's a
pretty standard law of physics makes a
lot of sense this guy is just Newton's
second law so this is just telling us
that mass times acceleration is force
the top one tends to be the mass
equation conservation of mass or the
incompressibility equation and the
second one is the momentum equation or
the small one in the big one quite like
that let's start with the little one so
you here this is our velocity so this is
just speed with a direction its
vector you might say U is equal to UV W
so we've got a component in the X
Direction a component in the Y Direction
a component in the Z direction how fast
the water in the river is flowing how
fast the air around a Formula One car is
going thinking about aerodynamics how
fast the custard is flowing off your
spoon any sort of movement of the fluid
the the speed and that motion is going
to be encapsulated by the velocity
that's the key thing about its motion
we've then got this other symbol here
nabla we do love our Greek letters in
maths so the symbol nabla is is telling
us what to do to our velocity u so nabla
is is a gradient it's a derivative it's
telling us to differentiate our vector u
in a particular way and the way it tells
us to do that is we have our three
components uvw and what we're going to
do is we're just going to do do u by DX
so differentiate the first bit with
respect to its coordinate which is X
it's the first coordinate the x
coordinate differentiate respect to ax
then we're going to add derivative of
the second one with respect to our
second coordinate dy and hopefully
you've figured out the pattern we're
then gonna add on DW by DZ so this is
the divergence of our velocity it's just
three derivatives so it's saying how
does the X component of my velocity U
how does that change as I move in the X
direction then how does V my Y component
change in the Y direction and how does
the third component W in the Z direction
how does that change in the Z direction
so this is equal to zero equation number
one this just tells us mass is conserved
now the second one the big boy so
Newton's second law in disguise so we're
expecting force equals mass times
acceleration here we've got you our
velocity and when we take a time
derivative of velocity that's exactly
what acceleration is you're going at a
speed you increase your speed you
accelerated your speed has changed with
respect to time or you decrease your
speed you decelerate it so that's what
the first term is going to describe and
then we also need the mass you
think of mass in this situation to be a
density so it's how you know fresh water
has a smaller density than saltwater so
saltwater is heavier in that sense but
it's you sort of mass and density are
the same thing when it comes to fluids
that's how you you sort of work with
those things so ro this Greek letter
here that is going to be our density so
this is our mass in that situation so
this is mass times acceleration that's
our new to second law of the left-hand
side and then all of this sort of stuff
going on over here these are just all
the forces so what we've got we have the
first two terms these guys are what we
call the internal forces so this is the
force between all of those fluid
particles hitting into each other
crashing sliding grinding past one
another there's internal force there and
then the third one
it's just capital F this is a bit of a
cheat because we just say this is our
external force F so this could be
gravity is the standard thing you would
normally you just replace F with G call
it gravity that's your external force in
most situations and if you want to go
really fancy you can put in
electromagnetism and we can sort of
combine navier-stokes with Maxwell's
equations and get magneto hydrodynamics
and that is how stars form and galaxies
form and that is just next-level how
your Stokes is hard magneto
hydrodynamics like try to model the
growth of the Sun as hard as it sounds
internal forces versus external forces
so it's just a sum of various forces
what are these individual forces so
let's look at the first one this nabla P
or grad of P so this is very similar to
our mass equation up here so the
gradient of P our pressure gradient it's
a vector representing the change in
pressure when there is a difference in
pressure a change in pressure high
pressure over here low pressure over
here the air moves from high pressure to
low pressure if there's a gradient
there's a difference in pressure between
two points that causes the fluid to move
between or along that pressure gradient
so that is creating a force so then the
final internal force this guy so this is
viscosity kind of what it's made up so
you've got all that you can
being in layers and it's slightly those
layers slide past one another they
create a friction and how strong that
friction is is is the viscosity so air
super thin air particles they move
around they do their thing it's all good
but if you've got like honey sliding
past other bits of honey it's very
sticky it's very thick much larger
viscosity so that's your second internal
force where's the problem with all this
this is why these equations are so great
because it's mass is conserved it's
Newton's second law it's all just makes
complete sense
there is nothing we have said here
hopefully that anybody can possibly
disagree with it's just Newton's second
law
move my fluid around mass is conserved
and this is why these equations work so
they've been around since the 1820s
1840s where navier-stokes both worked on
them and this is why they work this is
why we keep studying them but the
problem is we don't actually know if
they always have solutions they can be
used for almost anything you can think
of involving the fluid so they could be
aerodynamics of a Formula One car they
could be designing new aircraft to go
faster than the speed of sound this
could be blood flow around the body for
drug delivery maximizing the way the
drug is deposited to do with the blood
flow this could be pollution modeling
climate modeling ocean modeling or
anything involving a fluid it has to
satisfy these equations so these are
always your starting point but then the
problem is and this is why you get the
million dollars we just don't really
understand them mathematically in the
sense that when you have a set of
equations as a mathematician you want
this that set of equations satisfy three
particular properties first of all you
want a solution to exist you know got
equation you want to go right I already
able to solve it that would be nice
second of all you want a unique solution
you know if you did an experiment with
throwing a glass of water across the
room and they did it again and it did
something different no it's like a
loop-de-loop in the air it makes no
sense and then the tricky bit is you
want smooth solutions well-behaved
solutions like I've made a tiny little
change in how I started my
and I want the result to also just have
a tiny little change quantifying tiny
but not to blow up to infinity that
wouldn't make sense because I've changed
something so so small why have I got an
entirely different solution we've also
been taught that butterflies flapping
their wings and cause cyclones the
butterfly effects like a chain reaction
is one big leads to another leads to
another but in the in the sense of
having an equation you input something
into your equations like a function
machine you input some initial condition
it outputs what's gonna happen next
predicts almost like the future so you
start with your fluid it has some
velocity
how are you some pressure some viscosity
input it now your Stokes tells you how
that fluid is going to move you know you
can do these experiments so you know
what's gonna happen and you want the
equations to give you that result if you
tweak your velocity a tiny bit if you
did that experiment you'd get almost the
same result so you want that small
change in the starting point to lead to
a small change in the solution and this
is what we don't know about
navier-stokes we don't even know if a
solution exists all the time so given an
initial condition here's a velocity
here's a pressure input it we don't even
know if the solutions going to come out
so how come these equations are being
used by climate modelers and by Formula
One teams and all these things that you
tell me are using navier-stokes it
sounds like they're using a really
unreliable tool I wouldn't say is
unreliable because it's based on
standard laws of physics mass is
conserved Newton's second law so I think
everyone's happy that that makes
complete sense we've got that bit right
there's no reason for that not to be
correct but then the the sort of the
mathematical complexity of it the tricky
bit is we don't know if a solution is
always going to exist and so we kind of
find ways to cheat so we might make
simplifications we might make
assumptions to reduce some of these
terms or to remove time from the problem
or you can get ways around it by making
assumptions and making simplifications
so that's one way to use them and then
another way is to what's called
averaging so rather than having a
velocity field defined everywhere you
can say well what if I just take a big
circle of fluid take the average
velocity in that circle
and I want to know how that changes and
how that behaves that we can do so
that's called averaging Reynolds
averaging of the navier-stokes equations
and that is the kind of stuff that we do
in climate modeling because you can't
the computer power alone to model every
particle in the atmosphere like it's
gonna take longer than the life of the
earth to run that on current computers
so you just say well I'll just model the
atmosphere as patches of let's say ten
kilometer squared bits are there as long
as I know the average speed in that 10
kilometer squared I'm happy so it's all
about the averaging but mathematically
it should in theory be able to be solved
for each individual bit and that's where
we struggle I think the best way to
figure out what you need to do to get
the million-dollar prize to think about
what we've done already so we have the
equations they make complete sense with
happy with them mass is conserved new to
secular law great and then we also know
that solutions exist and they are well
behaved in two dimensions unfortunately
we don't live in a two dimensional world
we have to read I mentions so if we were
to ignore Zed and just have x and y are
two dimensions we can do it we can show
there's always a solution it's always
well behaved it works but then when you
go to three dimensions for whatever
reason it's just not working we can't do
it we have shown that weak solutions
exist so these are sort of rather than
being full solutions they're similar to
the averaging solutions not exactly but
like some form of solution we can get we
can get solutions when the initial
velocity is really small we restrict to
say we're only going to move at tiny
speeds to start with then we can show
solutions always exist we can show
solutions always exist for finite time
so so up to some you know time equals
100 or something we can get solutions
exist as well but we just cannot get
that they exist for three dimensions for
all of time for all possible initial
conditions so Tom will the person who
wins the Millennium prize be the person
who explains why that's the case like of
course you can't do it in three
dimensions and this is why or could they
possibly say yes you can do it in three
dimensions
silly-billy there was something you
didn't notice well what what will that
person do or what are they being asked
to do yeah so the the wording of the
millennium problem is fantastic it just
says further our understanding of the
navier-stokes equations it's it's the
most vague of statements but there are
some attempts that qualify or quantify
what that means it could be a case of
show that a solution always exists in
three dimensions for all possible
initial conditions or it could be a case
of as you said say well of course it's
going to blow up in three dimensions and
it's going to go to infinity and there's
we can't expect solutions to exist so
you can do it both ways the most recent
progress in 2016 by Terence Tao he
actually showed that for the average
navier-stokes equations that you do get
blow up in finite time the way he's
approached that could be a way of
showing that the full 3d equations could
also blow up in finite time so that
would be that we don't always expect a
solution so we don't really know which
way it's going to go I think one of the
key things is about understanding
turbulence so turbulence is this chaotic
random motion of air particles of water
think of two waves crashing into each
other in the ocean that is almost as
random and chaotic a situation as you
can get if you do that again you're not
going to expect the same thing it's it's
so so difficult to model and to
understand and fundamentally fluids they
just are turbulent not every fluid but
like air water rapids that's all it's
all turbulent and that's sort of I think
where the key problem lies because when
we plug our data into our computers the
computer averages things because it
can't solve for the turbulence it can't
solve for all those really small little
bits and all those little interactions
so it says I'm going to take this big
square and average the velocity or
average the length scale and that's the
way that we do it and it works but it's
not mathematically understanding the
equations practically we are happy with
navier-stokes we can use them the
equations for basically anything we want
it works it's great it looks amazing it
allows us to design all of these amazing
aircraft to fly into space all of this
stuff it works but it's just from a math
six point of view we just don't have
that proof it's a classic case of maths
wanting to know for certain rather than
just knowing that it works in every case
we can think of we don't have that proof
that it will always work or an
explanation of why it might not if I
gave you the dream computer that doesn't
exist and all the possible inputs you
need at the start this equation would
get you there it will just take a lot of
power you make a good point you can
import any bit of data any initial
condition you want but then the computer
may say oh but the solution goes to
infinity the solution blows up and of
course in a real situation we cannot
have a water particle piece of air
moving at infinite speed that just makes
no physical sense but the computer is
saying that's the solution so there's
some disagreement there between the
physical practicality of what can happen
and what the computer is outputting and
that would suggest that there's
something missing in our mathematical
understanding so you telling me that you
can input finite numbers into the Navi
of Stokes equation like realistic
numbers that would apply to something in
the real world and Navia Stokes spits
out impossible things like oh yeah your
River is gonna be flowing at infinity
miles per hour and things like exactly
yeah so that there's there's a really
the equations are wrong but but it's
conservation of mass that it's due to
the second law how can it be wrong this
is the this is the sort of paradox it's
it's everything we've done here makes
complete sense because these these two
laws mass is conserved Newton's second
law this will hold for any like this
works for a solid it's not just fluid
mechanics you do the same thing with
solid mechanics you get slightly
different internal forces but it's the
same it's the same set up so so there's
it doesn't seem like that bit should be
wrong you know it's it's conservation of
mass its force its mass times seller
ation there's no reason to think that
that's incorrect
so something somewhere is going wrong in
the mathematical understanding there's
an example about the flow of a fluid
around a right-angled corner like a
canal basically a canal but we've got a
really sharp right angle on the
now you stalled navier-stokes this says
that at this point this bright angle
corner I have infinite velocity if I
build this canal do I have an infinite
velocity canal I'm going to guess I
don't so it's it's that there's there's
no like everywhere else it works
perfectly but at this little point it's
saying my velocity is infinite but it
quite clearly isn't that's it in a
nutshell the equations work for all
possible practical uses so if you were
building this canal you'd be completely
happy you would know the speed
everywhere except one single tiny tiny
point but there there's a repetition
you're like why is it infinity why is it
infinity there I want to know and and
that's it that's we're obviously missing
that mathematical understanding there's
some difference there between the
physics of it and the equations we just
do not understand it that's kind of like
how division like just simple division
works and I use it every day it's just
this is one glitch where if you divide
by zero it kind of goes a bit weird yeah
that doesn't matter because I never
actually need to divide by zero exactly
there were always ways around it there
are approximately you know you know it's
a very large number so you just leave it
at that
so this is something that doesn't really
matter but it matters to you it doesn't
matter to any application of
navier-stokes but it does matter to
maths and it's the classic case of
alright if we solve it we have no
practical uses but to actually figure
out what's going on here the max we're
going to uncover it's gonna be brand new
it's gonna be stuff we've never looked
at before thinking of the problem in
entirely new ways and no doubt we will
discover new maths leads to all kinds of
other incredible new advances in all
this stuff to do with fluids it's just
you know all of these things that we use
navier-stokes for pollution modeling
climate modeling blood flow aerodynamics
all of these things if we really
understand the equations those things
are just gonna get better
tell me how much you love these
equations oh well they are my favorite
equations and just just to emphasize
the level of favoritism of these
equations the full navier-stokes
equations as written down in our piece
of paper
hang on which way around are we if we're
talking this if yeah so those should be
exactly the ones I've written down there
we go the little guy in the big guy dude
this is a first for number five on the
ribs as well the pain of the ribs like
that's I'm gonna say this is complete
commitment to two Navia steaks and fluid
mechanics why did you do that
well I my PhD was studying fluid
mechanics and these equations just they
just model it so I spent four years of
my life trying to not necessarily
understand them but studying them and
using them and it just felt like it felt
like the right thing to get pissed what
did what did the artist say when you
read he had a lot of fun with it so he's
actually he's quite an intelligent guy
he's got a load of like physics formulas
and he has a portrait of Einstein
tattooed on his back so he's really into
his physics and his maths himself so he
was saying I've never seen these what
are they so I sped the sort of two hours
of being tattooed pretty much do what we
just did and talking about navier-stokes